Britney Spears who has a book coming out
and in the book she says she had an
abortion when she was younger and while
she was dating Justin Timberlake there
was always a big question did they or
did they not you know did they do that
thing that only married people are
supposed to do guess the answer was they
did and Britney then became pregnant and
then she says she had an abortion and
she said if it had been left up to me
alone I never would have done it and yet
Justin was so sure that he didn't want
to be a father to this day it's one of
the most agonizing things I've ever
experienced in my life to which I say
many such cases there was a young woman
who wrote Into the show and she said hey
Michael I'm I've got an abortion
appointment but I know you're pro-life
so what do you think should I not do it
my first response was do not under any
circumstance go through with the
abortion you will regret at the rest of
your life